the surface duo a dual screen review
by me joanna stern yep this is the 399
surface duo and it's clearly not your
average android smartphone or
tablet it's got not one but two
5.6 inch displays and this 11 megapixel
camera which i'm using to record these
little selfie videos
so for this review i figured the best
thing i could do was take your video
screen
and split it right in half to show you
what the duo does
best oh and yeah you'll see random bugs
just happen on here
opening and closing helps but before i
explain the good and bad of having two
screens
let's take a look at this crazy thing
the duo has four positions
or as microsoft calls them this is a
book posture
posture posture do you remember this
posture i do
there's book mode where the two pop-tart
size screens give you a lot of real
estate
and how i ended up using this thing most
of the time there's single screen mode
where you flip one screen back
there's laptop mode though typing like
this is just
asking for carpal tunnel and tent mode
which is great for watching videos
i really like the hardware it's compact
like a paperback
or a moleskine notebook although many of
us wouldn't really want to put these in
our pockets
i'm calling it there's never been a
better time for a good old
fanny pack anyway great hardware
and for fourteen hundred dollars it
should be but software
not so much over the past two weeks of
testing i encountered
loads of performance issues and bugs no
not the crickets you hear outside my
garage where we've been shooting this
the ones that shouldn't exist on a
product this expensive nothing at all
a few days ago microsoft released a
software update that fixed some of the
issues
but certainly not all especially around
the slow and laggy performance
the company says it will continue to
deliver monthly updates to bring further
refinements to the surface duo
but when the software cooperated here's
where two screens were very useful
scenario one one app across two screens
on the left screen here is my gmail
inbox on the right
whatever new email i'm composing it's
been great whenever i needed to see the
original email i was responding to
on the left here is my list of notes in
onenote and on the right a blank page
for taking notes
but you need to buy the surface pen
separately powerpoint google calendar
and other apps also have this great two
screen view
many of microsoft and google's own apps
have been optimized though oddly not
skype which seems like a no-brainer for
this
the companies are working with other app
developers as well scenario 2
an app on each screen email on the left
web browser on the right calendar on the
left email on the right
youtube on the left one note on the
right you get the point
it's great to be able to see two apps at
the same time
as if you were working on a computer
with two monitors it's very easy to open
one
app on one screen and then another on
the other screen scenario three
reading on both screens yep this one's
pretty self-explanatory and sweet
it's like a real book except you know it
runs out of battery after a day
so if microsoft fixed all the software
bugs tomorrow this would be a
dream device not quite
there are just as many scenarios if not
more where it doesn't make sense to have
two screens
and definitely not two screens that fold
on top of each other
scenario one phone calls i don't think i
really need to explain this
any further if you want to test this out
for yourself try using one of these
things as a phone
microsoft does sell these 200 surface
earbuds
which sound pretty good but look like
drink coasters in your ears
scenario two one-handed stuff this is
awkward
this is also awkward even though you can
adjust the keyboard to be in the bottom
corner
scenario three quick access to the phone
you know what's not convenient every
time you want to look at your phone
this and especially not when you want to
take a quick
photo sure you can keep the screens open
like this but again
see scenario number two oh yeah the
camera's not very good either
so should you buy the surface duo
definitely not but that was not the
point of this review
the point of this review was to show you
how microsoft and google
are thinking differently about the
future of the phone or
tablet or whatever you call this thing
samsung's new galaxy fold 2 hints at a
similar type of future
where our devices transform when we need
them to do certain things
for a while i thought this whole thing
was a gimmick and unnecessary
but microsoft's first entry has made me
think differently about it all
next time just make sure the software
works oh and include a fanny pack